а сьогодні від європейської солідарності
хотіла би сказати кілька слів про наші
пріоритети міжнародної роботи і власне з
огляду на те які виклики стоять
найближчим часом На світовій глобальній
міжнародній арені перед Україною в той
час коли Україна продовжує свою
А таку Криваву брутальну боротьбу за
виживання за свій вибір за демократичний
вибір країни за відновлення взагалі
панування і функціонування міжнародного
права ми бачимо наскільки на сьогодні
А додається різних хаотичних елементів
до Міжнародного порядку денного ми
бачимо що виникають нові точки напруги а
нові військові конфлікти ситуація на
Близькому Сході очевидно а в
палестино-ізраїльському конфлікті в на
на Червоному морі з загрозами для
міжнародної торгівлі з атаками Ірану на
Пакистан ми розуміємо що всі ці речі
відволікають суттєво увагу наших
партнерів розмивають цю увагу і
примушують їх
одночасно пробувати вирішувати кілька
завдань у зовсім різних напрямках хоча
ми одночасно розуміємо що все це
елементи вісі зла яка активізувалася як
Росія Так і Іран так і Північна Корея А
які долучаються активно до зусиль
Російської Федерації проти України і
проти міжнародного світового порядку
терористичні організації які взаємодіють
і підтримуються з Російською Федерацією
На жаль все це спричиняє до того
що
Україна зникає в такому
активному в активній своїй присутності
зі шпальт міжнародних медіа іце це
означає що увага суспільна в
демократичних суспільствах також
зменшується по відношенню до України в
демократичних суспільствах Працює таким
чином що політики звертають увагу на те
як і на що чим переймається суспільство
і Очевидно це означає що сьогодні ми
бачимо меншу увагу до а не просто до
необхідності продовження допомоги
Україні а необхідності і нагальності її
військового нарощування фінансового і
гуманітарного нарощування і очевидно що
також бачимо Наскільки в багатьох
серйозних країнах наших партнерах
внутрішньополітичний порядок денний
перехоплює А ось цю важливу компоненту
розуміння і
усвідомлення необхідності допомоги
Україні як протидії набагато серйознішій
загрозі для всього демократичного світу
а саме продовження агресії Росії
Російської Федерації не суто навіть на
Україну а і на
країни Європейського Союзу на країни
Північноатлантичного Альянсу ці прогнози
почастішали в перспективі х-5ти років
але насправді ми з вами розуміємо якщо
Україна з допомогою наших партнерів
зможе зупинити і перемогти російську
федерацію на нашій території зможе при
призвести до поразки Російської
Федерації ніяких інших Атак а-а Росія не
зможе наносити ні на наших партнерів ні
в майбутньому на нас Я щойно повернулася
Як голова комітету з питань інтеграції
України до Європейського союзу з Бельгії
де була присутня на засіданні керівників
комітетів з європейських справ і
євроінтеграційних е е пріоритетів країн
членів е Європейського Союзу і партнерів
і ви знаєте
е ну там Бельгія презентувала свої
пріоритети є шість пріоритетів шість
головних тем на яких вона планує
фокусуватися протягом найближчих півроку
часу свого головування так от На жаль
Україна через кому разом зі з близьким
сходом разом з іншими викликами такими
міжнародними згадано просто окремо і це
на жаль означає що далі Зараз в країнах
Європейського Союзу зводиться фокус
уваги на внутрішні проблеми а ми з вами
пам'ятаємо Що наступне півріччя з 1
липня до кінця 24го року а в
Європейському Союзі головуватиме
Угорщина і там у нас іще менше шансів на
те що Угорщина буде пріоритизувати на
жаль необхідність допомоги і підвищення
допомоги України також ми з вами маємо
усвідомлювати що 24й рік це рік виборів
не тільки в Сполучених Штатах Америки не
тільки в Європейському Союзі назагал А у
величезній кількості країн
демократичного світу насправді 50%
населення світу цьогоріч буде проходити
через вибори ми бачимо як активізувалися
праворадикальні рухи ми бачимо
наскільки високим є
ризик ну принаймні якщо не приходу
повноцінно до там влади і до до владних
кабінетів
праворадикальних сил то ми бачимо
наскільки вони можуть змінювати
пріоритети і дії тих чи інших керівників
держави і тих чи інших лідерів і це
означає додаткові виклики для України
Одночасно ми з вами спостерігаємо за тим
як Російська Федерація збільшила суттєво
військовий свій бюджет як нарощує свою
взаємодію з вісь з країнами осі
зла як продовжує і зараз посилює знову ж
таки свої гібридні атаки на країни
вільного світу інформаційні операції
наскільки вона
також активізувала зуси по обходу
санкційного тиску і навіть має певні
досягнення в цьому в цьому контексті це
все означає що нам
потрібен змінювати свою зовнішню
політику переходити від емоційної
зовнішньої політики до більш
раціональної системної систематичної у
взаємодії між різними гілками влади в
Україні з залученням громадянського
суспільства і з серйозною взаємодією з
нашими партнерами які розуміють загрозу
яку на сьогодні утримує Україна і
стримує від цієї загрози захищає
країн-партнерів тому ми вважаємо що в
цій ситуації тільки посилення
спільнодії може і має бути відповіддю на
ці виклики з якими ми стикаємося в
міжнародній політиці і саме тому
плануємо нарощувати нашу е і подальшу
міжнародну активність і очевидно а
продовжувати взаємодіяти як із
міжнародними представниками посольствами
тут як з міжнародними медіа але також і
з нашими колегами партнерами в різних
країнах і в різних точках світу
рік буде
важкий
виклики дуже серйозні ми бачимо
наскільки
зросла критичність викликів в
міжнародній діяльності
і для нас
Єдність наших міжнародних партнерів
єдність світу по підтримці України
критично важлива бо ми ж розуміємо дуже
просту формулу чим більшою є підтримка
нас з боку наших міжнародних
партерів тим менше гине наше хлопців і
дівчат на лінії фронту і саме тому щоб
досягти цієї єдності
наших міжнародних партнерів перш за все
єдність маємо тримати ми і всередині
держави і в нашій міжнародній
діяльності європейська
Солідарність і вчора І позавчора і
сьогодні робить все щоб допомогти країні
досягти максимуму на міжнародному
треку з використанням знань авторитету
зв'язків Петра Порошенка інших членів
нашої фракції ми працюємо на багатьох
міжнародних треках Івана климпушценцаза
на треку
євроінтеграції Марія Іонова Ірина
Геращенко європейська Народна
Партія Я персонально також Ірина
Геращенко парламентської особле в бсє
Олексій Гончаренко Андрій Лопушанський в
парламентській асамблеї Ради
Європи Ірина фріс Парламентська асамблея
НАТО і це тільки частина з того що ми
намагаємося робити І сьогодні я б хотів
вам сказати
що внаслідок нашої активної
діяльності Петро Порошенко і інші
депутати нашої фракції запрошені на
міжпарламентську раду українанато яка
відбудеться в брюселі наприкінці цього
місяця Окрім цього Петро Порошенко Ірина
Геращенко Марія Іонова та інші депутати
нашої фракції запрошені на політичну
асамблею європейської народної партії
найбільшої
родини партії в Європейському Союзі від
якої критично залежить підтримка
України також Петро Порошенко і депутати
нашої фракції вже запланували візит в
великубританію для того щоб фіналізувати
закупівлю броньованих авто та
комплектуючих для fpv Дронів і
латліст Петро Порошенко та інші депутати
нашої фракції також запрошені на
мюнхенську безпекову конференцію і ми
зробимо все під час цих міжнародних
подій щоб підтримка України тільки
зростала бо ми вважаємо що всі наші
знання всі наші зв'язки всі наші
попередні зустрічі з багатьма
представниками різних парламентів світу
Сьогодні мають бути Вані з однією метою
не допустити роз'єднання наших
міжнародних партнерів і не допустити
зниження рівня нашої Міжнародної
підтримки хочу вам сказати що відносно
всіх цих відряджень документи на
керівництво Верховної Ради були
спрямовані
завчасно і я хочу вам просто сказати що
сьогодні вранці ми зі
здивуванням отримали листи від
керівництва Верховної
Ради від спікера пана стефанчука в тому
що Петру Порошенку Ну давайте говорити
відверто фактично відмовлено в візиті в
Брюсель на міжпарламентську раду
українинато цього разу посилаються
нібито на форму листа але хочу також
повідомити що
сьогодні повторно були подані всі
документи на керівництво Верховної Ради
щодо цього відрядження і ми щиро
сподіваємося
що влада в країні буде тримати єдність
так само як цю єдність тримає опозиція
ми щиро сподіваємося що влада і
керівництво парламенту підтримають всі
зусилля опозиції бо Яка різниця за
кордоном ми всі говоримо про Україну ми
всі говоримо на підтримку України і
підтримують ці зусилля для того щоб
міжнародна підтримка наша міжнародна
допомога не просто не зменшилася а була
збільшена А ви знаєте колеги Що Петро
Порошенко ще наприкінці Минулого року
подав свої позови до суду щодо дій і
керівництва парламенту і щодо дій
Державної прикордонної служби України а
я хочу вас поінформувати про те що вже
четверо депутатів фракції європейська
солідарсть Солідарність Володимир арієв
Олексій Гончаренко Ірина Геращенко Марія
Іонова подали свої судові позови на дії
спікера українського парламенту пана
стефанчука стосовно відмов або
бездіяльності щодо надання дозволів на
їхні міжнародні відрядження сьогодні
аналогічний позов стосовно відмову
чотирьох моїх відрядженнях протягом
чотирьох місяців звере вересня по
грудень Минулого року також подаю я
разом з адвокатами до суду на пана
стефанчука дуже сподіваємося що
українські суди
безсторонньо справедливо і чесно
розглядатимуть ці справи і очевидно
розуміємо що далі на часі позови на
обмежувальні
додаткові нові ініціативи спікера
стефанчука І власне позови Щодо його
перевищення повно важень і ви знаєте Я
хотів би закінчити однією дуже простою
фразою українська влада для вас ворог не
Петро Порошенко і не європейська
Солідарність для вас ворог Зрозумійте це
це Путін і Російська Федерація Дякую за
увагу дякуємо